j'aimerais vous montrer un truc vous
voyez cette banque en face je peux y
entrer en sortir en trois minutes et
faire quoi la braquer
bonne année
chaque ville a son roi à Ottawa ce mec
c'était Tony il y a peut-être pas été
plus loin que le collège mais j'ai un
doctorat en sciences de la rue j'ai
besoin de capital pour un travailleur
des sentiers battus et j'ai cru
comprendre que vous étiez l'homme à qui
je devais m'adresser je suis parfois au
partenaire et à l'ivresse personne n'est
mauvais en arrivant au monde comme tout
le reste ça demande de l'entraînement
il y a un souci monsieur il y a eu un
braquage de l'autre côté de la rue
cambriolages à l'échelle nationale ils
arrêtent pas de réduire les effectifs
parce qu'on ne fait pas de chiffres
enchanté écrase les avec ton succès
emmerder avec le sourire et si ça suffit
pas il te reste toujours de mal et
quelques phalanges pour trouver une
solution on unisse nos forces comment
créer une nouvelle vous voulez dire une
unité spéciale
merci Mère Noël
une femme une famille non je suis
disponible est-ce qu'il y a des choses
que je devrais savoir sur vous est-ce
que vous avez des projets petits secrets
je vais pas te livrer tous mes secrets
tout de suite je peux vous demander un
service
tu es la maison de qui
toujours rien à propos de lui rien du
tout non
si tu continues à faire ce que tu fais
de la façon dont tu le fais tu
deviendras millionnaire avant d'avoir eu
le temps de dire les mains
[Musique]
allô je crois que je viens d'assister à
braquage de banque combien de braquage
dans ce genre tu crois pouvoir faire il
faut que je fasse un dernier coup
il prépare un nouveau coup
il faut le retrouver maintenant où il va
recommencer bonjour j'aimerais effectuer
un dépôt sur mon compte que Dieu bénisse
la reine est-ce que l'un d'entre vous a
vu cet homme
en liquide